frères et sœurs, nous sommes un seul pays,
nous sommes un seul peuple
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il n'y avait aucune raison de croire qu'un
jeune garçon noir
à cette époque, dans cet endroit, puisse de quelque
manière que ce soit modifier l'histoire
[Musique]
Sud  L'Afrique est une sorte de pays aux
multiples races, il y a de la place pour toutes les
différentes races dans ce pays.
[Musique]
nous avons pris une décision après notre
arrestation mais nous ne sommes pas en faute, c'est
le gouvernement qui doit être accusé d'avoir
tué notre peuple.
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Je me tiens ici devant vous non pas en tant que prophète
mais en tant qu'humble serviteur de vous.
[Musique]
nous sommes ici aujourd'hui en tant que
représentants de millions de nos concitoyens.
les gens qui osent se soulever contre
un système social dont l'essence même est la
violence de guerre, le racisme, l'oppression, la répression
et l'appauvrissement du
peuple tout entier
[Musique]
vous ne gagnerez jamais, ce
beau pays connaîtra à nouveau l'
oppression des uns par les autres
[  Musique]
[Musique]